vacciner vacciner vaccinés depuis des
mois emmanuel macron n'a que ce mot à la
bouche
vacciner le jour vaccinait la nuit
vacciner le week end vacciner les jours
fériés merci à toutes celles et à tous
ceux qui ne comptent pas leurs heures
pour sauver des vies car c'est bien cela
dont il s'agit nous sortirons de cette
crise en vaccinant la france en
vaccinant le monde car le virus ne
connaît pas de frontières pour aider
tous les pays dans cette course 1
milliard de doses ont été livrées avec
kovacs vacciner vacciner vacciner avec
solidarité on continue une dose de doses
trois doses c'est ce que le gouvernement
demande à présent pour pouvoir conserver
son pas salutaire qui pourrait devenir
vaccinale d'ici la fin de la semaine
après l'examen du conseil
constitutionnel
alors en israël on a déjà un temps
d'avancé puisque la quatrième dose est
déjà de mise face à omicron une dose de
rappel pour l'heure réservé aux
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans aux
plus fragiles et au personnel soignant
l'état d'israël continuent d'être à
l'avant-garde de l'effort mondial pour
faire face à la pandémie les citoyens
d'israël ont été les premiers au monde à
recevoir la troisième dose du vaccin
contre locaux vides 19 et nous
continuons à faire oeuvre de pionnier
avec la quatrième dose également sauf
que voilà une étude menée chez à
l'hôpital sheba près de tel aviv affirme
que la quatrième dose de vaccin n'est
pas suffisamment efficace contre le
variant omicron le vaccin qui était très
efficace contre les variantes précédent
est moins efficace contre le variant
souche omicron compte tenu des données
exclusives du centre médical sheba sur
la maladie au micro parmi ses employés
participant à la grande étude
sérologique nous comprenons que malgré
l'augmentation significative des
anticorps après le 4e vaccin cette
protection n'est que partiellement
efficace contre le variant omicron qui
est relativement résistant aux vaccins
du côté de pfizer on ne sait pas
vraiment sur quel pied danser d'un côté
on affirme que le vaccin actuel est
toujours aussi efficace contre mikron
mais de l'autre qu'un vaccin plus adapté
devrait être prêt en mars en clair
le vaccin est parfaitement adapté à osny
crohn mais le prochain le sera encore
plus je ne sais pas si on en aura besoin
je ne sais pas si ni comment il sera
utilisé mais nous serons prêts lusine a
déjà commencé la production nous
espérons pouvoir arriver à un produit
qui protégera beaucoup mieux contre les
infections en particulier car la
protection contre les hospitalisations
et les cas sévères est assez raisonnable
avec les vaccins actuels si vous avez eu
la troisième dose la quatrième dose de
vaccin n'est pas à l'ordre du jour en
france mais le ministre de la santé l'a
considère déjà comme une possibilité je
n'ai pas de réponse formelle à vous
donner je vous dis juste qu'on est
totalement ouvert à cette perspective et
que s'il faut aller devant les français
et leur dire qu'une nouvelle dose de
vaccination est nécessaire pour protéger
les plus fragiles nous le ferons même si
omicron est moins virulent que les
précédents variant à quatrième dose ne
devrait pas être la dernière à en croire
le pdg de pfizer qui militent aux
surprises pour une vaccination
renouveler advitam eternam
le scénario le plus probable c'est que
le virus va continuer à circuler de
nombreuses années encore c'est un virus
qui s'est diffusé dans le monde entier
et il est très difficile de s'en
débarrasser mais je pense qu'avec les
outils créés par la science cette vague
sera la dernière avec autant de
restrictions pour moi il est important
d'avoir trois doses pour une vaccination
complète puis une dose par an sauf pour
les personnes immunodéprimées qui
pourrait se faire vacciner tous les
trimestres
miser sur la vaccination de masse pour
tenter d'enrayer l'épidémie face
invariants owni crohn moins dangereux
une stratégie en demi-teinte puisque les
quatre contamination explose en france
comme en israël d'ailleurs
l'organisation mondiale de la santé l'a
dit elle même aucun pays ne pourra
sortir de la pandémie à coups de dose de
rappel t dose de rappel en cascade qui
pourrait à terme affaiblir le système
immunitaire c'est en tout cas ce que
craint l' agence européenne du
médicament
si nous avons une stratégie dans
laquelle nous donnons des rappels disons
tous les 4 mois environ nous finiront
par avoir des problèmes avec la réponse
immunitaire et la réponse immunitaire
pourrait ne pas être aussi bonne que
nous le voudrions donc nous devons faire
attention à ne pas surcharger le système
immunitaire avec des vaccinations
répétées et malgré les différentes
sonnette d'alarmé certains dirigeants
font la sourde oreille à croire que le
coronavirus fait aussi parfois
endommager l'audition